[Music]
it's been the biggest joy to be able to
do this again just be welcomed into this
group and they're like hey come play
with us let's go across the world and
meet all these people and do this
amazing show this is great it's not a
concept for me it's not an idea I can
get inside of your experience and
understand who you are and that's like
the ultimate expression of why being a
sense8 is called a in love with these
people the show says that all the show
touches people that drama this show has
actually changed people's lives
profoundly the last three years were
gone since I've totally changed my whole
brain this is so much bigger than what
we even eat she's just this whole flash
of memories from different cities in
different countries on different
continents it's this like unspoken bond
that you have with people and you feel
like part of this this group that
spreads a message all over the world
that is so much bigger than anything
else that there is on TV right now as
long as we hold onto the idea that
there's love we can be incredibly
connected measured by the impact it has
on human beings lives and their hearts
small and large acts of love and caring
and of looking out for one another and
that will be a true revolution I feel
very lucky to have been part of this
journey it helped me expand and grow as
a person as an artist it's nice that
we're all here together we get to see it
off together this is a special moment
and one that I will remember for the
rest of my life
[Music]
oh hello welcome to the sensing left I'm
glad that the universe conspired to rely
on what was off-center the minute the
decision was made everything has been
super speeding incredibly high-octane if
he had to go go go
[Music]
last season our show builds bridges and
powers people we all bleed when were cut
we all have the same thoughts we all
feel grief and love it's always been
about that common humanity it's a show
that is for every we are surrounded by
the best quality of human beings that we
could have it's been beautiful
every it's a real joint every set
location they're there by the dozens it
was nuts I've never seen anything like
that it's because of the show from a
Brazilian like really crazy but a really
professional then we also get to be a
part of that see them and listen to
these stories and possibly use that
energy while filming all those people in
every country they are our extended
cluster it just feels like a big ball of
love my goodness water churning they are
proud to be a part of this
tabi that we can give them an end that
was satisfied
you
you